you can see just the tail end of the
rain as it's kind of making its way
across the east valley but there is a
little bit more on the west side this
shot from
the the rampart casino resort out on the
west side on west charleston where they
picked up some pretty good rainfall
let's check temperatures right now we're
in the 40's around the valley 30's up
there at kyle canyon and there has been
some snow up in the mountain we'll check
that in a moment but let's check rain
totals four hundredths of an inch of
rain so far officially so that is just a
hint just a skosh of what we should have
by now at this time in january it's been
somewhat of a dry january for us for
sure in a couple of ways we needed the
rainfall so we needed the snowfall too
as you can see the snow cats are out
there grooming the trails right now
the snow kind of winding down boy it was
coming down heavier over the last few
hours and in the middle of the night you
can see the low clouds there hugging the
mountainside but there has been at least
a it looks like at least a couple of
inches of snow for us up there at lee
canyon that is so nice to see eight
hundredths of an inch of rain out at red
rock this morning and we've seen eight
hundredths of an inch out on west
charleston down at mountains edge we've
seen that as well as well as anthem
hills park but boy just east of
henderson over a tenth of an inch of
rain and almost a tenth of an inch in
boulder city the wapa valley you've kind
of missed out on this system and prompt
you haven't had much either in lincoln
county nil because this system has just
moved up into the las vegas valley and
southern clark county and if you watch
the motion it moves north and then it
starts to slide south it's a little bit
like a see-saw teeter-totter it's going
up and now back down and then it's going
to start to pull away from us still have
that pretty good cell that you can see
from our camera this is the dark area
back here over on the east side that's
now pulling away over henderson and over
towards the mountains and then
eventually out to lake mead but it looks
like the north end of the valley is
really winding down with any chance of
rain sandy valley still getting some
showers and southern clark county all
the way down to searchlight with a few
showers for laughlin right now in
boulder city you're still going to get
some rain out of this but this wave
could be the final wave of real rain
with just a chance of some light showers
left over the next hour or two 48 for
the mountain with some partial clearing
through the afternoon the rain and snow
this morning and then over the next hour
or two things will start to really wind
down we'll get some breaks of sunshine
for the valley too this afternoon at 60
degrees but this morning pretty socked
in with the clouds so far and the rain
through the morning commute and then by
lunchtime don't worry about it you'll
just need that umbrella for the morning
commute after today wow look at all the
sun in our eight day forecast breezy
winds on friday highs in the mid to low
60's all week with mornings in the 40's
and upper 30's